territoire portion identifiés et
appropriée de la surface de la terre de
cette définition cyclo pedic
l'association versa image en tire une
exposition à chacun avaient quartier
libre pour exposer sa vision du
territoire donc parfois c'est un
territoire plus tôt descriptif
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué on a
aussi une des visions c'est la notion de
tribus à la date et la population d'un
espace qui délimite un territoire
on a aussi des territoires au niveau de
la photo animalière 150 photographies
entraîne le spectateur dans un voyage
sans fin résultat d'une réflexion
initiée depuis le mois de septembre
grand ou petit format couleur ou noir et
blanc dix neuf photographes se sont
prêtés au jeu et partagent leur vision
je fais beaucoup de photos animalières
en fait j'ai fait un focus sur les
libellules parce que ce sont des
insectes qui m'a qui me passionne il y
en a beaucoup qui ont disparu si on
enlève les moeurs si on enlève tout ça
disparaissent et donc la notion de
territoire pour moi était importante par
rapport à elle
je suis parti du principe que finalement
faire une photographie s'est posé un
cadre s'est posée donc des limites dans
un espace et que ses limites des limites
justement un territoire le territoire
photographique dans lequel on va y
projeter un certain nombre de choses
dans lequel on va interpréter un certain
nombre de choses
c'est un territoire propre en france à
l'étranger sur la terre ou dans les airs
les photographes vous font découvrir des
trésors cachés de territoire